in the world of communication we have
two dominant approaches monologue and
dialogue and they both have implications
for how we come across as leaders so
let's discuss these and unpack the
details hello again friends Alex Lian
here in this channel communication coach
is here for rising leaders like you all
the videos here are to help you increase
your personal impact so you can lead the
people around you to higher levels of
excellence and so if you haven't yet
subscribed I encourage you to do so now
big part of leadership is your
communication style are you more likely
to monologue with people or dialogue so
a monologue is where you communicate in
a one-way fashion where you mostly talk
at other people not with other people
when your monologuing there's not a lot
of invitation to exchange ideas or for
them to take a turn and check for
understanding typically the goal of a
monologue whether you realize it or not
is you're trying to get your idea into
the other person's head so that's one
approach now generally speaking people
don't really like to be on the receiving
end of a monologue it tends to push
people away the next time they see you
coming it's very likely that they'll try
to over voyage you at least I probably
would so second let's look at the
dialogue approach to communication a
dialogue is by definition two ways
there's lots of turn-taking lots of
invitation going back and forth in the
conversation both verbally and
non-verbally the goal of this is not to
implant your idea into somebody else's
head but instead to reach a mutual
understanding or a shared meaning now
that does not mean that you agree with
what the other person is saying and
they've convinced you you just
understand where they're coming from and
you can appreciate their point of view
in an accurate sense so at least you do
clearly follow what they're saying now
somewhere along the line you're probably
going to run into a clever salesperson
or somebody who really has some
experience and they will be monologuing
at you but they're still doing this
thing where they're taking turns
there it seems like there's some
invitation you're having a conversation
but in the end they're steering you
toward their desired outcome I've heard
a lot of skilled salespeople drive me
toward their way of thinking so they're
still trying to get their idea into my
head and that's still a monologue what
Martin Buber calls a monologue disguised
as a dialogue so when I ask you do are
you more likely to monologue or a
dialogue I'm talking about a dialogue in
the genuine sense where you actually
desire a mutual exchange of ideas so
question is a day
are you a monologue er or a dialogue er
I hope I'm saying that right I would
love to hear your questions in that
section below so thanks god bless and I
will see you next time